It was irresponsible.
Irresponsible?
Absolutely.
They spent what, a trillion dollars
plus countless man hours.
Not to mention political capital,
trying to get one dude back from Mars.
Political capital? It united the world.
Yeah, for a hot second.
But, what if they failed?
Everyone would have been like,
um excuse me.
You know, there are
people dying here, right?
People are always dying on Earth.
You can't change that.
But if you get the opportunity
to bring back Matt Damon.
No, screw Matt Damon.
That's just harsh!
Dude, it costs an average of
$1,200 to save a life.
12, what?
When you give money to charity,
the ones that are
actually going to save lives
are the ones that clean water and
give out medicine and stuff, right?
Matt Damon's charity
literally cleans water.
So when you factor in
administrative costs
and how many people would
actually die without help,
that works out to
1,200 bucks per life.
Okay, so what you're saying is
you take a trillion and divide it by 1,200
and you can save 833 million
people's lives on Earth?
You just do that math right now?
I'm wicked smaht.
I know.
It's just you look, like, so dumb.
Okay.
Checkmate.
Dang.
Boom.
Okay.
You really don't think
they're sending anybody to save us?
I mean,
I'm sure they're doing what they can.
Within reason.